bonsoir 34e numéro du 7-8 politique et
ce soir une édition spéciale les 13 et
20 mars les électeurs de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines iront aux
urnes pour désigner leur nouveau député
valérie pécresse ayant décidé de
démissionner au lendemain de son
élection à la présidence de la région
ile de france au cours de la prochaine
nous vous proposons donc un débat entre
les candidats qui s'affrontent dans ce
scrutin ils sont 9 8 sont en plateau
colette jardin algérienne candidate du
parti communiste ne pouvant pas être
présents que ce soir pour des
obligations professionnelles le débat se
fera en deux séquences d'une demi-heure
j'accueille tout d'abord pascal thévenot
bonsoir vous êtes le maire de vélizy
candidats elle est rudy et modem tristan
jacques bonsoir quand ceux-là du parti
socialiste maire adjoint de magny les
hameaux vincent colo bon soir vous êtes
le candidat du front national
responsable du front national jeunes
dans le département des yvelines
et puis à juliet naked knitter candidate
europe ecologie conseillère municipale à
guyancourt
voilà pour les présentations votre temps
de parole sera chronométré pour
respecter au mieux l'égalité on va
revenir tout d'abord sur 2012 second
tour de l'élection valérie pécresse et
qu'ils l'emportent avec +2 58% des
suffrages face au parti socialiste une
participation de 60% seulement on le
sait lors d'un scrutin partiel il est
beaucoup plus difficile de mobiliser
quel message allez donc vous faire
passer aux électeurs vous leur dites
quoi pascal techno aux électeurs qu'ils
viennent aux urnes
il faut toujours se mobiliser une
partielle c'est difficile mais s'il veut
le défendre leurs idées ont généré on a
les élus qu'on mérite donc ça dépend de
chaque électeur et une partielle quel
que soit le sens de leurs votes c'est
participent au scrutin
sachant vous avez fait l'union dès le
premier tour avec le but c'est d'avoir
une
candidature consensuelle de la droite et
du centre pour représenter mes valeurs
et puis des idées qui sont malmenés
aujourd'hui restant jacques votre
message aux électeurs
petite précision vous n'avez pas fait
l'union autour de la gauche pour le
premier tour non au second tour je
l'espère en tout cas on a des keys à la
question qui se rejoignent ce qu'on me
disait qu'il serait dans ce cas le
problème que je défends qui est un vrai
premier de gauche je suis toujours
socialiste juste pas sûr que le
gouvernement soit encore sur certains
points donc c'est un vrai drame négo de
gauche que je défends et je pense qu'il
nous reste encore 16 mois de demande
avant la prochaine élection
présidentielle et qui nous reste encore
six mois pour faire avancer à différents
sujets dont on pourrait discuter tout
cela il y aura plusieurs thématiques
abordées au cours de la prochaine demi
heure et on parlera notamment cette
réforme travail qui occupe notamment les
députés qui vont occuper à les députés
et vous serez amené à vous prononcer
d'ailleurs sur le projet qui devrait
être présenté à la fin du mois de mars
vincent colo pour le front national quel
message vous passez aux électeurs
aujourd'hui sur la question de la
mobilisation toujours difficile pour une
législative partielle sur écoute et
c'est une nouvelle élection donc c'est
surtout l'occasion pour projecteurs de
dire non une bonne fois pour toutes en
fin du mois une nouvelle fois il est se
sont déjà exprimés lors des régionales
lors des départementales massivement au
premier tour pour dire pour dire non à
cette coproduction ump s est là c'est
encore une nouvelle occasion l'occasion
de faire entrer un député supplémentaire
3 cc peut demander lorsqu'on est un
parti qui représente 30 % des électeurs
donc ce sera l'occasion de porter une
nouvelle voie à un réel changement qui
change de
qui change réellement la politique que
celles proposées actuellement par le ps
et l'ump
pour terminer ce tour de table et vous
ne m'en voudrez pas même si c'est
aujourd'hui la date de cette émission
c'est la journée de la femme et on
terminera journée des femmes on
terminera ce premier tour de table avec
vous sur le message aux électeurs est
peut-être la question de l'union aussi
qui a été rapidement abordé alors je
vais vous corriger si la journée
internationale des droits des femmes
c'est pas pareil c'est pas la fête des
femmes mirage journée de la femme
bastien convaincu non mais écoutez moi
je pense que
il faut absolument aller voter pour ces
élections parce qu étant donné le
contexte politique actuel la tension qui
règne en france et les dégâts que que
fait notre gouvernement actuel je suis
de gauche je suis pourtant je vois ce
qui se passe il me paraît absolument
indispensable d'envoyer l'assemblée
nationale une députée qui qui puisse
faire contrepoids qui puisse porter des
idées des valeurs qu'ils soient
réellement de gauche n'est pourtant pas
d'union autour d'une seule candidature à
gauche des premiers tours pourquoi pas
d'union autour d'une seule candidature
et bien parce que
malheureusement voisin ici présents
représentant du gouvernement actuel
parti socialiste au pouvoir il nous a
dit que ce n'était pas tout à fait mais
il part sous les couleurs du ps s'il
partait sous les couleurs et oui et donc
donc pas possible d'union au premier
tour peut-être le deuxième tour vers en
parlant brièvement du cumul des mandats
tout de même puisque on rappelle que
valérie pécresse a démissionné pour ne
pas cumuler même si la loi n'oblige pas
quelle est votre position sur cette
question pascal thévenot du cumul des
mandats sachant pendant cette campagne
vous a déjà reproché d'être maire
vice-président de versailles grand parc
également que je reprécise aussi qu'en
2017 le cumul du mandat de maire et de
député sera interdite par la loi normale
ont dû normalement après une loi peut
être fait c'est pour ça que les risques
rappelle du changement de temps qu'à
valérie pécresse c'est un engagement et
puis c'est un monde à quasiment
nationale on parle d'une région au
capital dont cas là c'est à la fois un
mandat local mais une vision nationale
tu représentes cette région alors qu'un
député je pense qu'un député au sol
c'est ce qu'il ya de moins souhaitait
finalement par
tous nos citoyens mois les billysiens et
ne demande qu'une chose c'est d'être
député maire et les habitants de ma
circonscription en fait sont intéressés
puis je pense que le mandat de député
maire c'est un des plus beaux mandat on
défend à la fois on est la vraie vie sur
le terrain sur chaque chaque jour est la
vraie vie vous l'avez pas
obligatoirement au palais bourbon
si vous êtes complètement hors sol et je
pense que les meilleurs députés qu'on a
eu on a eu dans la circonscription
robert wagner franck borotra vers les
pécresse ils avaient tous un mandat
national
et puis une attache de terrain et j'ai
la chance en plus de bien que nature que
cette circonscription
tout à fait d'accord victor cas de
villefort même vous démissionnerait de
votre opérateur chose que je ferais pas
pour moi le cumul des mandats mais on a
déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler avec
pascal pour moi c'est un non sens le
député un rôle important dans la
démocratie
ils votent les lois contre le l'action
du gouvernement il et rédige donc pour
moi qui ai 45 % des députés qu'ils
soient mer n'est pas une bonne chose
puisque on doit se consacrer 100% à sa
tâche c'est à dire être un député à 100%
pour vous dites voilà il faut un député
pas qu'il ait des pudeurs sol mais je
pense qu'à d'autres manières de d'aller
vers les gens et d'autres manières de
concevoir la démocratie et je pense que
pour ce que j'ai proposé dans dans
certains des documents c'est
l'instauration d'un conseil législatif
locale l'idée c'est de une fois par mois
les voir nos concitoyens pour ceux qui
sont intéressés de présenter des textes
qu'on que l'on discute qu'on débat
dont on débat au parlement et de
travailler que sur des possibles
amendements notamment ou d un moment que
je pourrais porter au parlement et pour
moi c'est une des meilleures manières de
par des députés leur sol comme vous le
précisez est à la fois de ce contrat
intéressant pourcentage puisque comme
vous savez notre pays a besoin d'avancer
il faut les députés pour cela attendre
complet vincent collet du côté du ps on
écoute et de républicains sur cette
question aucun des deux je vais vous
dire non aux centristes
je vais vous dire nous on est absolument
contre le cumul des mandats pour une
raison simple c'est qu'un mandat de
maire ou un mandat de député ou un
mandat de hockey ou n'importe quel autre
mandat est un mandat à plein temps on
doit se consacrer à 100% attache sa
voulez vous l'avais dit je n'en
disconviens pas maintenant il faut
mettre le lait vos paroles sur des actes
on voit que le parti socialiste comme le
comme l'ump
les républicains sont quand même les
champions
le champion des cumulards maintenant ou
jamais voilà maintenant nous on est
absolument contre le cumul des mandats
c'est une loi qui nous paraît bonne
et on la respectera bien évidemment pour
europe écologie la position écoutez moi
je vais commencer par saluer la la
ce café valérie pécresse en
démissionnant de son mandat de député
comme ça elle pourra se consacrer
pleinement à son nouveau mandat de
président devant les électeurs europe
écologie qui soutient la décision de
participer très bonnes décisions il faut
être objectif
de toute façon l'écologie n'est ni
vraiment droite ni vraiment de gauche
emmené écologiste avant tout et donc
et puis c'est bon pour la démocratie
enfin qu'une présidente de grézian fasse
son boulot et fasse que ça c'est parfait
et effectivement qu'un député soit la
fois maire et député ça me paraît
difficile pour faire les deux s'est je
sais pas comment vous avez géré à gérer
votre emploi du temps et puis par
ailleurs vie vous êtes quelqu'un de
terrain je pense que vous avez des
adjoints des premiers adjoints des
conseillers municipaux qui pourront
faire le relais si vous démissionnez le
vote mandat de maire donc oui j'espère
que les candidats ici présents
démissionneront de leur deuxième mandat
si jamais ils sont élus voulaient
apprendre pascal thévenot
oui non j'ai répondu après on parle de
la région en fête ses 12 millions
d'habitants 12 milliard de budget après
il faut que ce soit en harmonie avec
humour je dirige une ville de 20 mille
habitants et c'est une question
d'engagement de travail et c'est pas que
je n'ai pas des élus qui puisse me
seconde et une seconde tous les jours
mais je pense que le quotidien c'est
important et gelé à la fois avec mes
association avec tous les citoyens que
je rencontre tous les jours et même les
entreprises et je pense que
encore une fois le député ne pas être
seul emploi à présent la réforme qui est
porté par la ministre du travail ce
fameux projet el ghomri assouplissement
des 35 heures l'entreprise aussi et qui
pourrait décider de moduler le temps de
travail et les salaires des employés
pour rester compétitives quels sont vos
différents avis sachant que le projet a
été repoussé au 24 mars
est-ce que déjà vous l'auriez votée en
l'état je vais vous passez la parole
tout d'abord vincent collet on fera un
point sur les temps de parole vous avez
un petit peu de retard
si je là je la voterai en étant élu
absolument pas d'ailleurs je remarque
donc c'est une loi soit disant soi
disant socialiste du moins de votre
gouvernement qui aurait été voté par
valérie pécresse elle annoncée celle est
encore député donc on voit encore cette
nouvelle coproduction d'un côté le ps
qui est qu'il a proposé de l'autre côté
l'ump qu'ils la votent non même si sage
divise au sein de chacune des familles
politiques où il mais en attendant ils
sont comme d'accord sur sur les points
majeurs de
de cette loi non en réalité c'est cette
loi ne vise qu'à une chaussée à
précariser l'ensemble des salariés alors
sous couvert sous couvert de flexibilité
du travail ça c'est souvent ce qu'ils
demandaient par le medef notamment
et encore une fois le parti socialiste
et le gouvernement se coucher devant
leurs revendications quand on voit qu'il
va y avoir une majoration des heures
supplémentaires que cette majoration par
nous on va passer de 25 % à 10 % qu'on
va faciliter les licenciements alors que
normalement on devrait faire le
contraire on devrait faciliter les
embauches faciliter les tpe les pme qui
représentent ou notre tissu industriel a
embauché non là on préfère faciliter les
licenciements
c'est tellement c'est tellement logique
et évidemment je ne parle pas du
communautarisme qui va rentrer justement
qui rend qui est écrit dans cette loi
qui va permettre de rentrer dans les
entreprises
le rapport benda terre qui va permettre
à chacun d'exprimer ses propres
revendications religieuses
donc évidemment en plus ça se trouve le
les parlementaires ne l'a nous la
voterons pas majoritairement et comme le
veut la démocratie
médine parti socialiste ils vont à tous
les coups faire passer encore une fois
le 49-3 ce qui est une entrave à notre
démocratie restera que vous passez la
parole on entend des réformes portées
par le gouvernement socialiste mais vous
vous êtes contre 1 7 restants vous dites
sur le fond comme sur la forme on va
dans le mauvais sens tout à fait rond va
dans le mauvais sens l'emploi ce facteur
majeur d'intégration dans la société
aujourd'hui on à 3,5 à 5 millions de
chômeurs en france et notre gouvernement
nous propose des vieilles recettes
puisque après 30 ans compte proposer la
même chose c'est-à-dire la base des
cotisations sociales la dérégulation du
marché de l'emploi et le retour de la
croissance
ça fait trente ans qu en moyenne on
dépasse pas sur 10 ans 2 % de croissance
quand on sait que il faut entre 2 et 3%
pour créer de l'emploi de croissance
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on puisse
réfléchir à un nouveau modèle c'est
notre le député aussi de proposer de
réfléchir à des nouveaux concepts qu'il
faut réinventer notre modèle de gauche
et compagnie alors ma proposition
déjà c'est d'en discuter avec les avec
les soignants puisque françois hollande
s'y est engagée de restaurer un dialogue
avec les syndicats et les citoyens les
entreprises et malheureusement ils ne
respectent pas donc je pense que déjà il
faut en parler avec les citoyens mais
pour ma part je pense qu'il faudrait
réfléchir à une nouvelle baisse du temps
de travail
une des politiques est efficace sur les
dix dernières années comme l'a montré le
rapport u10 de monsieur thierry benoit
les 35 heures ont réussi à créer 360
mille emplois sur les années 2000 ce qui
est une des politiques le petit casse
qui a été fait jusqu'à nos jours
je dis pas qu'elle était parfaite vous
peut-être la revoir peut-être
l'améliorer peut-être la faire
différemment et sage
il faudra qu'on en discute avec
l'ensemble des acteurs mais je pense que
c'est dans cette direction là qu'il faut
qu'on aille parce qu'elles savent nous
est plutôt favorable comme valérie
pécresse à cette réforme vous qui venez
du monde économique
la moyenne du monde de l'entreprise est
votre première question ça si elle est
présentée le 23 mars
si je suis député je la voterai acier
dans l'art est dans les temps en fait je
pense que c'est comme les présenter à
l'origine enfin et s après c'est une
autre phase est un tout un problème
peut-être du politique il n'ya pas de
l'entreprise la conduite du changement
ça s'apprend et je pense que c'est plus
une erreur politique de ce gouvernement
qui aurait dû présenter des ses
orientations dès le début et les amis
avec une conduite du changement on est
pas simplement là dire voilà c'est ça ou
rien et c'est ce qui bloque général
toutes les évolutions dans notre société
mais moi je viens du monde du travail il
faut arrêter de penser qu'un chef
d'entreprises licencient pour le prouver
le plaisir moi j'ai embauché beaucoup
j'avais une société qui avait 110 ans
salarié et je n'avais qu'une envie
c'était d'embaucher plus et surtout ça
coûte cher on quand on prend quelqu'un
on a envie de continuer donc par contre
quand on veut défendre une pme ou une
tpe là le problème principal c'est la
vision du carnet de commandes et
pourquoi aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
90 % des gens qui sont embauchés en cdd
c'est simplement parce que sarah sur la
pme la tpe et c'est là de pme la tpe qui
créent les emplois et simplement si on
pouvait le rassurer sur la possibilité
de rupture en cas de baisse de commandes
en cas de difficultés eh ben je suis sûr
que les tpe et les pme embaucherait
beaucoup plus est sûre ça il faut pas
avoir peur de la sortie puisque
aujourd'hui si les tous les employés qui
ne sont au chômage et s'employer qui
s'inquiète aussi c'est pas que certains
politiques qui ne viennent pas de biens
français y compris des biens qui ont
fait pétition avec plus d'un million de
signatures c'est inédit oui mais c'est
comme les maires en fait les gens sont
contre l'homme politique mise adore la
mer et que pour l'entreprise c'est la
même chose les salariés globalement
mesures énoncées lors une image de leurs
soldes des chefs d'entreprise mais ils
adorent leurs chefs d'entreprise et
leurs entreprises
donc en fait c'est simplement une
question de confiance il faut partir du
principe qu'on doit tout faire pour
sécuriser à la fois le salarié mais plus
dans la faune dans la formation et
s'occuper enfin de du chômeur le
chercheur d'emploi on en reçoit tous les
jours en mairie
et aujourd'hui c'est la précarité a
l'air je vous interromps puisque vous
êtes un peu plus de quatre minutes les
chronomètres on va vous les afficher
dans un instant juste après votre
réponse sur cette question justement de
l'emploi sur cette réforme
vous la voyez cette réforme je la
voterai pas c'est très fin pour moi
cette réforme c'est la loi du
licenciement et facilite les
licenciements ça veut ça veut dire
faciliter la façon licencier les gens ça
veut pas dire améliorer les embauches
donc non je la voterai pas et moi même
qui travaillent qui vient aussi du monde
en entreprise mais en tant qu'employé je
suis je travaille comme intermittent du
spectacle je subis plein fouet la
flexibilité les les gens qui vous
appelle la veille pour travailler
lendemain et qui vous relie 106 le
lendemain parce que finalement il ya
plus de travail
je sais ce que c'est que d'avoir des
difficultés dans la famille de devoir
travailler les week-ends on ne veut pas
savoir ce qu'on va faire le lendemain
donc j'espère que tous les français ne
vivront pas ça et cette loi va va donner
ça va généraliser ce mode de
fonctionnement qui est absolument
absurde et destructeurs pour pour la vie
les gens
donc non je ne voterai pas c'est toi et
d'ailleurs ce qu'il faudrait faire c'est
pas rallonger la durée du temps de
travail ou flexibiliser l'emploi ce
qu'il faudrait faire c'est créer des
opportunités d'emploi par exemple en
amorçant la transition énergétique en
créant des emplois dans les énergies
renouvelables en créant des emplois
locaux en installant des agriculteurs ou
biologiques en haye ap tout en isolant
les logements en donnant du travail à
nos pme de cette manière voilà c'est ça
qu'il faudrait c'est pas c'est pas
casser le monde du travail et casser du
travail tout simplement on va faire
juste une pause pour regarder ces temps
de parole les trois domaines qui vont
s'afficher juste après elle nous
parlerons de l'agriculture c'est l'une
des spécificités de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines elle est
passée diverses différentes dans ses
aspects il ya a trait aussi bien vélizy
qui est plutôt porté sur l'urbain que le
rural avec des communes comme saint rémy
les chevreuse magny les hameaux aussi
par exemple ou saint lambert des bois il
est différent temps de parole qu'on va
me redonner parce que je n'ai pas mis
mes lunettes
l'oreillette que je puisse bien les voir
et voilà et on va tout d'abord parlé à
de cette question donc du monde agricole
et je vais vous laisser la parole
justement pour europe ecologie les verts
puisque vous avez l'idée de développer
tout cet aspect écologique l'aspect
environnemental l'aspect agriculture
c'est le message aussi vous fait passer
pendant cette campagne c'est qu'ils
m'ont fait une campagne qui est très axé
sur la santé l'environnement
l'agriculture ben moi je pense qu'il
faut arrêter mon tir aux agricultures à
aux agriculteurs l'agriculture intensive
l'élevage intensif la course à
l'endettement c'est pas les solutions ça
ne marchait pas avant le voir et essayer
de il faut il faut vraiment proposer
commencé à proposer aux agriculteurs à
s'orienter vers autre chose à amorcer
une transition agricole si je puis dire
et une transition technologique parce
que l'agriculture de pointe c'est une
agriculture qui est une agriculture
agriculteurs technologique et du coup
bas pour ça il faut développer le bio le
local la permaculture les circuits
courts pour que les agriculteurs ne soit
plus dépendant du cours mondial du blé
ou de la viande mais pour qu'il puisse
s'adresser directement aux voisins ou
ville d'à côté et du cookie qui puisse
gérer eux mêmes leurs prix et se verser
un salaire décent et est d'ailleurs dans
ce cadre là je pense que nous avons tout
près de chez nous sur notre
circonscription le plateau de saclay
plateau de saclay qui est menacée
d'urbanisation et moi je propose que ce
plateau sackler reste à vocation
uniquement agricole combien ça des
agriculteurs bio qui puisse nourrir nos
enfants de nos écoles en bio en local
sainement sans pesticides sans s'en
créer des futurs malades de cancer et et
concret la même occasion la même
occasion des emplois dans l'est du
plateau de saclay la fusion entre le
département des yvelines est celui des
hauts-de-seine ça vous inquiète aussi
parce que vous dites ça ferait une
réserve foncière pour les hauts-de-seine
mais effectivement parce que les
hauts-de-seine sont est un département
très riche qui n'a plus de place pour
pour construire par contre les yvelines
on a encore beaucoup d espaces vides de
beaux espaces naturels et on a un petit
peu moins de sous donc l'idée de cette
fusion 78 92 ce serait en fait de
prendre l'argent du 92 et de construire
sur notre plateau de saclay dans 78 par
exemple donc effectivement de la fusion
78 92 c'est un petit arrangement un
petit peu malsain et j'espère qu'il
n'aura pas lieu vincent colo ont parlé
notamment de l'agriculture le salon de
l'agriculture a fermé ses portes il ya
pas très longtemps
marine le pen a été plutôt bien
accueilli par les agriculteurs
d'ailleurs oui très bien pas comme
françois hollande par exemple mais ça
pour une raison simple c'est qu'il ya
d'un côté un parti qui a complètement
assassiner si je puis dire les
agriculteurs quand je dis un parti je
parle je parle des domaines nous à côté
de ça on propose une toute nouvelle
politique de rupture c'est à dire nous
on souhaite nationaliser notre politique
agricole
c'est à dire on arrête avec la pac parce
que on donne 20 milliards d'euros à
l'union européenne qui nous en rang 13
c'est à dire il ya quand même un delta
on perd 7 milliards d'euros
nous ce qu'on propose c'est de faire une
politique agricole française une paf est
en fait cet argent ira directement aux
agriculteurs et deuxièmement nous ce
qu'on veut c'est les protège également
les protégés de la concurrence des lois
internationales déloyale notamment
on sait que le que les partis au pouvoir
actuellement ultra libéraliste sont pour
la concurrence libre et non faussée
notamment mais qu'est-ce que ça engendre
cette concurrence la saint-jean de la
crise porcine notamment
vous êtes bien au courant quand on voit
que les le prix du kilo de du kilo de
porc en allemagne et à 1,32 ou en
espagne à 25 alors que celui en france
et à 1,55 à peu près comment voulez vous
qu'on soit concurrents et comment
voulez-vous pour préserver et protéger
nos agriculteurs aujourd'hui nos
agriculteurs lancent des cris d'alarmé à
vous au gouvernement à celui que vous
représentez aujourd'hui sur plateau mais
également à vous or aujourd'hui on ne
leur qu'est ce qu'on leur propose
allez on leur balance une petite somme
quelques millions pour les calmer non en
réalité il faut changer de politique
préservez préserver leur préserver leur
leur emploi leur donner envie de
retravailler nationaliser la politique
agricole leur donner les moyens de se
protéger face à la concurrence et
surtout que l'état fasse une priorité ce
qu'on appelle la priorité nationale que
les marchés publics aillent en priorité
à nos agriculteurs aux agriculteurs
français et pas l'union européenne et ça
c'est un gros problème parce que ça
l'union européenne l'interdît
aujourd'hui sans que l'on vous êtes à
peu près à cinq minutes de temps de
parole pour europe ecologie les verts
environ 5 minutes 30 pour la liste des
républicains vous avez une petite minute
de retard sur tout ça vous êtes à 4
minutes donc je vais vous repassez la
parole dans un instant et tristan
tristan jacques parent dont vous êtes le
plus en retard aux états peinent à 3
minutes donc votre réaction sur l'aspect
agricole et puis aussi pour revenir sur
notre bassin véritablement cette
opération d'intérêt
nationale paris saclay vous aussi vous
dites il faut préserver un petit peu
tout ça et regarder comment ça se
développe bien sûr il faut préserver
tout ça il faut préserver l'ensemble de
temps à l'école il faut préserver le
rapport entre habitat logement et emploi
effet les acquis des entreprises et
notamment l école aux espaces verts
il faut réussir avec les cdt qui ont été
signés sur sur le territoire à protéger
tous ces éléments là après au niveau de
l'agriculture
il faut promouvoir à mon sens une
aventure qui permettent à la fois aux
agriculteurs de vivre et aux habitants
de se nourrir
ça peut paraître simple comme ça mais
faut arrêter de spéculer à mon sens
universel sur les matières premières est
pareil c'est de réfléchir aux nouveaux
modèles sur ma commune on a installé
j'en cocagne qui produit des paniers
biologiques format sur mme annie
labrousse
il ya quelques il ya quelques il ya
quelques années il ya deux ans on a
installé un maraîcher biologique celle
de robert pires est qui qui produit
paraît toute la semaine une cinquantaine
de paniers et qui donc alimente les
familles danoises et avec la salle verte
m et je pense que c'est l'addition de
plusieurs modèles comme celui ci qui va
permettre de résoudre cette crise
profonde et pas par l'intensification
des productions agricoles comme à ce
qu'on a actuellement question la
question agricole en plus elle est
importante sur ces constructions comme
vous le dit puisqu'on à la fois le
plateau de saclay puis oui mais il faut
pas oublier le parc naturel de la vallée
de chevreuse inquiets sont de fortes
odeurs agricole et je pense qu'à travers
tout ce qui s'est dit il est clair que
il faut pousser une agriculture que je
dirais raisonner mais si on est il ya
disproportion de concurrence avec les
pays qui nous entourent
c'est fois c'est revient à la politique
de l'emploi avec
des normes qui sont bien plus
importantes à ce qu'on veut toujours
être le premier de la classe qui leur
sont imposées par rapport à ce qu'impose
l'europe en fait on dit toujours
l'europe mais ce n'est pas l'europe
c'est la france avec des charges qui
sont beaucoup plus importantes et un
agriculteur ils mentent pas avoir des
subventions ils n'ont simplement à vivre
de sa production est dignement et je
pense que c'est à la fois des réformes
qu'on n'a pas fait la réforme de
l'emploi qu'on n'a pas fait et puis les
circuits courts
moi dans ma commune dans toutes les
cantines en fait ben j'ai des
approvisionnements qui viennent soit de
la ferme de viltain ce soit d'autre
agriculture produite sur le plateau de
saclay où le parc naturel régional de la
vallée de chevreuse et là par contre on
a toute notre part de responsabilité en
tant qu il eut local pour pouvoir avoir
amélioré tous les sites you cours et on
se retrouve des industriels qui peuvent
aussi avoir intérêt à aider et à
valoriser cette culture donc il paraît
il faut pas opposer les uns aux autres
mais je suis d'accord que on doit vous
permettre un agriculteur de vivre de sa
production restera que vous avez une
minute de retard dont un peu plus de
cinq minutes à peu près temps de parole
sont vincent collet aussi une petite
trentaine de secondes parce qu'on va
bientôt passer aux conclusions dont
convard et afficher les chronomètres et
si vous voulez réagir sur cette
thématique là donc d'être une thématique
on n'a peut-être pas le temps d'aborder
ces liens 18 du grand paris ça fait de
près de près de quatre ans qu'on se bat
au près là c'est du vent paris pour
qu'on puisse enfin enfouir offert cette
ligne puisqu'il traverse le plateau de
saclay
sur 17 qui m de long donc entre la lune
fait orly et versailles
donc voilà j'invite tous les habitants à
se mobiliser sur sur l' enquête publique
qui va débuter le 21 avril le 21 mars
pour qu'on puisse
on puisse renflouer cette ligne sort de
l'ensemble des partis politiques tous
les habitants quel que soit le résultat
de cette élection un sens colo juste
avant de passer en conclusion si vous
souhaitez agir sur la thématique
agricole bondir sur la question de la
mise
oui bien sûr alors premièrement sur la
thématique agricole je suis également
entièrement favorable aux circuits
courts nous c'est ce qu'on a toujours
proposé à la fois pour des raisons de
proximité mais également écologique
on voit souvent les les héros ce que je
peux appeler les euro soumis convaincus
qu'ils aiment beaucoup
toujours dans le cas de
l'ultralibéralisme aller chercher des
produits qui viennent d'autres pays
évidemment avec les émissions carbone
qui s'enchaînent derrière donc nous on
est toujours sur cette problématique sur
sa problématique locale
il faut absolument que les collectivités
territoriales s'approvisionne notamment
donc les mairies les écoles et est même
plus sur les reprenne nos agriculteurs
nos agriculteurs locaux et ça je
souhaite que ce soit vraiment imposé
imposé sur cette circonscription que
chacun chacune de nos collectivités
puissent puisse faire travailler nos
agriculteurs notamment dans la vallée de
chevreuse sur le plateau de saclay on va
afficher une dernière fois de les
chronomètres on va passer aux
conclusions avant de poursuivre ce débat
une seconde partie avec quatre autres
candidats qui se présentent sur cette 2e
circonscription le premier tour se
déroulera donc être dimanche on va
commencer avec vous écologie les verts
ont une trentaine de secondes vous aurez
à peu près 30 secondes chacun oui alors
moi je vois qu'ici tout le monde est
très écologiste
ça fait vraiment récupération si je puis
me permettre
parce que dans les faits on voit que le
ps ne fait absolument rien pour
d'écologie que la droite boudeuse toutes
les droites confondues ne font rien non
plus que sont nos territoires nous avons
des permis d'exploration de gaz de
schiste qui ont été délivrés par vaux
majorité respectives et que les discours
c'est bien beau mais qu'il faudrait
peut-être passer à l'acte et m faire
pour de vrai du circuit court faire pour
de vrai du bio du local protégé pour de
vrai nos terres agricoles parce que vous
votez tous le tracé du métro sur le sur
le plateau de saclay suis la seule ici à
avoir voté contre à mon conseil
municipal
donc effectivement quelques mots pour
conclure voilà la santé avant tout la
santé de nos enfants du local du bio et
de l'emploi créé par
ces emplois ne passe encore une
trentaine de huy pour conclure une mode
pour les circuits courts encore une fois
on est absolument pour on l'a toujours
été
malheureusement lorsqu'on souhaite
favoriser les marchés publics français
faire de la priorité nationale on a tout
de suite les partis européistes dont
vous êtes les dignes représentants qui
s'offusquent en disant c'est scandaleux
vous n'avez pas le droit de faire de la
priorité nationale
j'en passe et des meilleurs donc
question écologie je vous invite à venir
chez nous vous verrez un programme ultra
détaillés et qui sera bien plus efficace
maintenant lorientais 5 secondes pour
conclure j'ai grandi dans tout le monde
a décidé à aller voter pour mettre un
terme à cette politique est ravageuse
pour notre environnement pour nos
agriculteurs pour nous pour nos salariés
et et voter pour un député pour un parti
qui fait le choix un réel choix de
l'alternance et donne une toute nouvelle
politique tristan jacques parce qu'elle
était dans un jour je pense qu'il faut
changer la manière dont on fait de la
politique il faut un député à temps
plein il faut rapprocher les citoyens de
l'assemblée nationale et du ski tg
engage à venir si je suis élu discuter
avec moi de l'ensemble des taxes qui
sont présentés au parlement tous les
mois est de discuter rédiger les
armements avec moi que je pourrais
porter par la suite j'ai engagé aussi à
retrouver toutes mes propositions sur le
site internet tangente point fr jaber
notamment l'écologie l'emploi l'habitat
l'éducation et les enjeux locaux
merci pour votre soutien une petite demi
heure pour débattre c'était assez fort
pour faire tous les aspects convient
pascal thévenot votre conclusion
entre nous c'est clair
en fait je m'en vais avec passion je
m'engagerai dans ce mandat est pour elle
l'écologie et bien longtemps qu'elle
fait partie du paysage et qu'elle est
intégrée dans tous les partis politiques
tous les programmes le grenelle ça a été
fait il ya d'autres choses qui ont été
faites mais avant tout ce qu'on doit
défendre c'est avec pragmatisme l'emploi
parce que c'est ce que souhaitent nos
familles non plus une famille cherche de
l'emploi de la sécurité c'est aussi un
sujet important et c'est un sujet auquel
on est confronté dans nos communes tous
les jours donc si on pouvait mener des
actes à nos paroles de ben ça serait le
pour le plus grand bien de tous nos
citoyens donc qu'une chose mobilisez
vous et est ce que l'on sait faire sur
nos territoires je le ferai assemblée et
votez donc le 13 mars pour ce premier
tour merci à tous les quatre d'être
venus échanger autour de vos différentes
propositions dans quelques instants
les quatre autres candidats vont venir
aussi échanger sur ce plateau marque
juste une pause avec un micro trottoir
que pensez vous de cette démission de
valérie pécresse son départ entraînant
donc cette législative partielle dans
les yvelines
oui elle a eu raison absolument pas trop
si elle s'est engagée il ya pas
longtemps en plus ce qu'elle a été élue
donc c'est un peu c'est un peu gênant
motion enfin bon je suis d'accord avec
cette émission puisque je suis contre le
cumul des mandats en bas j'étais un peu
déçu parce que j'aime beaucoup valérie
pécresse c'est quelque chose de pas
habituel pour la région parisienne et je
trouve ça très bien pour ce normal c'est
son engagement et le cumul des mandats
ne me convient pas non plus a
normalement le double mandat ça devrait
annuler depuis longtemps donc ma foi ça
peut être bien à elle se concentrera
beaucoup plus sur une mission que sur
plusieurs le 7-8 politiques spéciales
législative partielle dans la 2e
circonscription se poursuit avec à
présent donc en plateau et je vais
essayer de pas me tromper
vous ne m'en voudrez pas didier
blanchard donc candidat elle nous
citoyens ancien premier adjoint vélizy
dans l'opposition aujourd'hui nous avons
également max alain obadia
voilà qui se trouve là candidats
nouvelle donne et jérémy misé candidats
france écologie pas jamin lacombe pour
yvelines pour tous va également nous
rejoindre merci donc à tous les quatre
d'être venu également échangé bienvenue
sur ce plateau je vous redonne les
règles le temps de parole est
chronométré pour respecter l égalité
bonsoir à vous installez vous également
candidat donc pour line pour tous ne
tombez pas tout de suite
il reste une petite demi heure
d'émission encore la première question
la même chose que pour les quatre autres
candidats qui étaient là tout à l'heure
comme hobby mobiliser pardon sur une
législative partielle c'est toujours
difficile
et quand la formation politique et est
un peu moins connus également sans être
péjoratif c'est peut-être encore plus
dur de faire revenir les électeurs
on va commencer avec vous oui
effectivement dans une législative
partielle est toujours délicat de faire
déplacer des électeurs mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un enjeu quelque
part principalement dans ma commune où
on s'aperçoit qu'on a notre candidat qui
est en passe de cumuler les mandats ce
qui n'est pas accepté par la population
et je crois que ça va être un élément
important qui va mobiliser les vénitiens
et les habitants les citoyens parce que
j'aime bien par les citoyens ex quelque
chose qui est repris par beaucoup de
candidats et tous les citoyens de la 2e
circonscription qui aujourd'hui sont
comme les 80000 les 80% des français qui
se sont déclarés opposés au cumul des
mandats c'est qui me paraît aujourd'hui
tout à fait normal dans la vie politique
actuelle on va dire qu'on dit la
nouvelle donne oui bien sûr
effectivement vous avez raison la
question est un peu complexe de
mobiliser les gens sur une élection du
site hâtive partiel cela étant faut pas
perdre de vue l'objectif que les
législatives
et quand même un débat national bien que
ce soit également un débat local
comme vous avez pu le constater la
situation du pays est quand même
relativement catastrophique
le chômage est très important on nous
dit qu'il y à trois millions et demi de
chômeurs mais en vérité si on cumule
toutes les catégories de chômeurs nous
en sommes plutôt à 6 millions voire à 8
millions si l'on compte les désespérer
ceux qui ont été radiés pour des raisons
administratives
nous avons aujourd'hui un enjeu
climatiques très très important nous
avons un problème de partage du travail
nous avons toute une série de problèmes
qu'il s'agit absolument de de dénouer au
mieux de l'intérêt de nos concitoyens
donc nouvelle donne est un parti nouveau
qui se proposent de d'innover de créer
des solutions tout à fait nouvelle pour
tenter de répondre à tous ces enjeux qui
se présentent à nous aujourd'hui et qui
sont d'une urgence absolue
le collectif nouvelle donne qui est né
en gardons du collectif roosevelt 2012
qui avait été initiée notamment par
stéphane hessel je n'ai pas repréciser
absolument présentation benjamin lacombe
candidats yngling pour tous mouvements
plutôt proche de la manif pour tous à
l'origine on veut situer voilà votre
slogan pour la vie tout simplement
c'est spécial message que vous allez
faire passer pendant cette campagne dans
un sénat s'est fait passer le message
mais surtout alors moi à la différence
on n'a pas de preuves de mobilisation
est en fait ma grande surprise c'est
d'abord vous dire de la joie d'être là
avec vous et la joie d'être avec des des
candidats qui en fait amène des idées et
pas des tactiques et cette joie en fait
elle est allée à les partager parce
qu'on s'est rencontrés mais surtout moi
ma grande surprise c'est aperçoit qu on
n'a pas de preuves nous à mobiliser les
gens donc j'en ai lu deux choses c'est
que 1 quand les idées sont là en fait
vous avez des gens qui suivent et que
deux en fait causer des tactiques
politiciennes vous avez personnes en
attendant on a du monde sur tous les
marchés
on a des traits dans toutes les boîtes
aux lettres on a des affiches partout et
on a des gens qui ont des convictions à
défendre et quand il ya des convictions
et bien en fait vous avez des des
bénévoles nous n'est que des bénévoles
et ont financé une campagne je verrai
ton c'est à dire de pas de deux
professionnels pas et on est aussi bon
que peu de moi j'espère visé pour france
écologie c'est aussi bon que tous les
autres candidats
voilà
c est effectivement difficile de
mobiliser mais je pense que justement
les citoyens attendent des nouvelles
propositions de nouveaux visages
nouveaux mouvements autre que les partis
traditionnels installés depuis des
années et des années et des années
un récent sondage disait justement que
près de 78% des français n'est pas à
voter pour quelqu'un issu d'une
formation politique
donc votre formation c'est france
écologie ça veut dire que vous vous
présentez comme une alternative à europe
écologie france écologie été créé en
2001 par isabelle jacono et dominique
julien labruyère qui est cofondateur du
pnr de là va être je pose donc est un
mouvement qui était assez discret qui se
présente est assez rarement aux
élections qui est les plus discutés avec
l'ensemble des élus pour essayer de
faire avancer leurs idées ils ont décidé
d'un petit peu plus s'investir sur le
terrain électoral récemment avons des
différends d'idées justement va tout de
suite parlé de l'emploi si vous le
voulez bien la réforme de la ministre du
travail
le projet el ghomri donc assouplissement
des 35 heures je le redis à l'entreprise
qui peut aussi décider de moduler le
temps de travail les salaires des
employés pour rester compétitives texte
qui sera présenté le 24 mars il ya un
léger report d'une quinzaine de jours
par rapport à ce qui avait été annoncé
est ce que vous le voteriez ce texte si
vous êtes élu alors pour être très clair
sur ce sujet il est bien évident que le
monde du travail a changé que le code du
travail doit être revue on s'aperçoit
que dans certains pays en quatre cinq
mois on a réussi à modifier les choses à
faire baisser les taux de chômage
prendrait comme exemple l'italie
mais en france on a toujours le même
problème à partir du moment où on a
parti qui fait une proposition partie
d'ailleurs qui n'a pas été élu pour
traiter ce sujet ce n'était pas dans les
danses qui avait présenté le président
landes dont je comprends que sa base
soit un peu contre ce projet qui par
ailleurs contient des éléments qui sont
positifs nous citoyens nous considérons
que à droite comme à gauche moussante il
y a des gens compétents partout et des
idées qui peuvent être prises et traiter
ensemble pour faire avancer le pays ce
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas possible avec
les partis traditionnels
ce qui fait que nous
une troisième voie quand j'exclus les
extrêmes qui sont départis refuge qui ne
sont souvent que des fétus de paille qui
ne dureront pas en terme de vote qui
sont plutôt des votes de sanctions nous
nous sommes là pour proposer des
solutions pour faire évoluer notamment
monde du travail
il est bien évident qu'il faudra faire
bouger les lignes on a des propositions
à faire dans ce domaine
et si je suis élu député nous
travaillerons ensemble avec les citoyens
pour amener une vues communes sur ce
problème de l'emploi mais pas imposées à
la hussarde un texte qui n'est pas
correct de mon fils lui aujourd'hui
donc vous ne le voteriez pas en tout cas
contre lorsque je ne voterai pas toutes
les parties qui peuvent être dans ce
texte
mais il ya quand même du bon dans ce
texte a pour nouvelle donne parce qu'il
ya du bon dans cette interview elle
serait plutôt de propositions si vous le
permettez je vais vous faire un petit
parallèle vous savez en 1974 et le mou
schmitt disaient les profits
d'aujourd'hui sont les investissements
de demain et les emplois d'après demain
on a vu avec le recul que finalement la
seule chose dont on pouvait être sûr
c'était que les profits d'aujourd'hui
étaient les profits d'aujourd'hui
rien de plus aujourd'hui on nous dit
pour créer de l'emploi il faut pouvoir
assouplir les conditions de licenciement
et il faut allonger peut-être le temps
du travail jusqu'à le temps de travail
jusqu'à environ 60 heures la seule chose
dont on se rassure à l'identique de la
citation que je faisais tout à l'heure
c'est que faciliter les licenciements ne
fera qu'une chose c'est faciliter les
licenciements
comment peut-on croire aujourd'hui en
allongeant le temps de travail
on va créer des emplois nous a nouvelle
donne nous proposons linverse nous
proposons de venir à la semaine de
quatre jours
nous proposons les 32 heures par semaine
vous savez eurostat qui est un organisme
indépendant qui dépend de la communauté
européenne
notez que les 35 heures lorsqu'elles ont
été posées ont créés ou maintenus
environ entre 350000 à 600 700 mille
emplois aujourd'hui la réduction de
travail c'est la seule solution pour en
sortir et créer de l'emploi
je terminerai si vous perdez avec un
salaire constant juste pour assurer
éventuellement les
différents salariés vous savez alors
attendez je vais vous répondre
aujourd'hui il ya 400 entreprises qui
sont passés aux 32 heures dont certaines
très célèbres comme mamie nova comme
fleury michon comme la macif et les
présidents de ces entreprises n'arrêtent
pas de se féliciter d'avoir fait cette
mesure car la productivité a augmenté je
suis maman expert comptable et
commissaire aux comptes des métiers et
j'ai affaire à des entreprises toute la
journée
effectivement nous pouvons imaginer un
système socialement discuter de
réduction du temps de travail massive
pour créer des emplois de manière
étudiez élaboré et éventuellement avec
des réductions de salaire au canada vous
faire une petite confidence au canada
quand une entreprise perd 20% de son
chiffre d'affaires que se passe-t-il
al'inverse dc où on licencie raid 1 % de
salariés ont réduit le temps de travail
de tout le monde de 20%
ça rejoint un petit peu le projet de loi
travaillant sociétés ont réduit ont
réduit la paye des salariés et c'est
l'état qui compense en tout ou partie de
la perte de pouvoir d'achat qui découle
de cette baisse il vaut mieux financer
des gens en poste que de payer des
chômeurs ça évite la désespérance
sociale
ça maintient le savoir faire et ça
dynamise une entreprise ils viennent
pour se combattent et l'ultralibéralisme
alors ce projet de loi elles
s'inscrivent dans une logique
ultralibérale alors moi je sens très à
l'aise avec ça parce qu'en fait j'ai mon
entreprise et donc c'est en fait c'est
la différence d'ailleurs je pense entre
le la réflexion qu'on a eu et la réalité
des hommes politiques si on veut de moi
j'ai ma pme qui marche bien on est 100
salariés est en fait cette fois elle va
dans le bon sens cirque il n'y a pas que
la partie
comment dirais-je code du travail déjà
le connaîtra et vous savez est
incompréhensible donc nouer entreprises
elle a 5 ans donc je vous invite si vous
demain voulait créer votre entreprise a
essayé de comprendre la droite variable
cinq ans donc c'est incompréhensible et
en fait sa demande à chaque fois un
expert donc déjà effectivement cette loi
va dans le bon sens parce que elle
permet d'assouplir un peu des règles et
une raclée en entreprise que ce qu'on
appelle la règle de subsides
subsidiarité
c'est à dire que les bonis sciences ont
pris part les gens dans l'entreprise
avec les patrons d'entreprises et ça
c'est une règle de base et après moi le
message il est simple c'est de laisser
les entreprises travaillent et voilà
diminué diminuer les charges les cds
libre et la 1% de cotisations sociales
patronales -38%
quand exactement ciel salariale et c'est
le problème de l'agriculture alléger les
charges mais il est peut-être sur la tva
c'est un autre débat mais surtout moi je
vous dis laissez les centristes rankin
et cette loi va dans le bon sens et elle
me paraît un truc fondamentale et j'ai
entendu des syndicats là ça m'énervait
sacrément c'est sur la partie
prud'homale on se rend pas compte du mal
que peut faire en fait des indemnités
donner un salarié sur une pme une paix
mec qui fait un million et quant à une
condamnation prud'homale pour des
erreurs effectivement juridique mais sur
lequel parfois on est désemparé le ça
protège aussi le salarié jouit si vous
voulez l'entreprise d'où l'idée du
plafonnement qui me paraît mais
évidemment
pleinement pleinement pertinence et la
loi et protectrice elle doit le rester
ok mais de façon raisonnable quand vous
couler la boîte parce que vous avez un
gars qui a dit oui moi j'ai un préjudice
ok mais ce qu'on a pensé au préjudice
d'un noir de salariés qui sont là depuis
plus exact l'ami d'années dans
l'entrejeu en valeur mais oui mais cela
s'il coule
les douze autres ou les 13 autres qui
restent vous dites quoi vous fermer
l'entreprise parce qu'il y en a un qui a
eu effectivement un énorme préjudice et
qui doit couler l'ensemble non on met
des ce que propose la loi qui est très
très bien des indications raisonnable il
faut être raisonnable entreprises c'est
pas une vache à lait l'entreprise c'est
pas l'argent tombe pas du ciel c'est
l'ensemble des travailleurs de
l'entreprise qui amène l'argent
donc on est là qui dit moi je veux tout
parce que j'ai l'impression qu'il a cool
imaginons on met des seuils c'est très
très bon ce qu'a fait je vais être en
basse - tant que patron mais j'applaudis
des deux mains
voilà et j'encourage manuel valls très
bien exactement gouvernement qui en a
bien besoin simplement à un moment il va
dans le bon sens à la veille de la
mobilisation de demain france écologie
sur le plan économique sur le plan de
cette loi déjà cette loi travail vous
êtes élu demain vous la beauté non non
moi à titre personnel je la voterai pas
pour la bonne et simple raison que je
trouve dommage c'est que ces grandes
lois on met un peu tous font qu'il ya
toujours des gens qui m'ont aidé à
cordes des points moins d'accord avec
d'autres et au final ce sacré que des
conflits et ça n'avance jamais donc je
pense que le gouvernement ferait mieux
de refaire des propositions plus
travailler sur chaque thème est les
proposer une par une
ah ok je travaille pas ne s'appellerait
pas la grande loi madame belle connerie
mais ça avance et d'être plus vite sur
le thème de l'emploi et des bons points
peut-être qu'il faut oui plafonner les
indemnités aux deux mâles peut-être par
contre je ne suis pas certain qu
augmenter à 60 heures par semaine voire
douze heures par jour le travail va
créer de l'emploi je ne suis pas sûre de
cette loi véritablement va créer de
l'emploi mais plutôt comme des monsieurs
aussi quand fascicule licenciement
licencie plus facilement mais pour moi
il n'y a pas de concret dans la création
d'emplois
on va pas baisser les charges
concrètement on ne baisse pas la tva on
ne soutient pas les l'innovation rien
pour l'emploi véritablement vos
propositions en france écologie pour
soutenir l'emploi
soutenir les commerces de proximité
l'artisanat c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans
votre programme et notamment mes immole
écologiste je pense qu'il faut consommer
cours à proximité
mais pour ça il y en a qui des candidats
écologistes qui propose qu'il faut
brider les commerces à proximité et des
circuits courts nous concrètement ce
qu'on propose c'est vraiment de baisser
les charges sont les petits commerces
face à la grande distribution
je ne propose pas d'augmenter les
charges de grande distribution mais au
moins d'aider les petits commerces à
avoir une concurrence plus loyale visé
vide mais c'est hélas où les produits
bio non pas pour enrichir encore plus
les agriculteurs le bio d'ailleurs ce
l'agriculture qui s'en sort bien et pour
permettre que les prix baissent et le
choix de consommer bio donc encouragés
par la fiscalité par la baisse des
charges ou la baisse de la tva la
consommation et donc l'emploi risque
aussi les petits commerces sont beaucoup
plus créateurs d'emplois que la grande
distribution
on va afficher vos différents temps de
parole je sais vous vouliez réagir mais
vous êtes déjà un petit peu en avance un
peu plus de trois minutes chacun si vous
voulez avoir encore un petit peu de
temps les temps de parole donc qui
s'affiche pour nouvelle donne c'est un
peu plus de trois minutes
benjamin lacombe également j'ai un ami
bizet vous avez encore un peu de retard
je vous repassez la parole dans un
instant et didier blanchard à 2 minutes
30 de temps de parole pour cette seconde
partie du débat de la deuxième
législatives qui nous intéresse ce soir
les sujets qui ne manquent pas et qui
concerne finalement aussi le local en
cette 2ème circonscription des yvelines
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'entreprises du
côté de vélizy par exemple et puis il ya
aussi beaucoup de terres agricoles voilà
ça peut aussi concerner cette 2e
circonscription saint rémy les chevreuse
magny les hameaux par exemple sont des
communes de cette 2e circonscription
france écologie
vous leur dites quoi aux agriculteurs
qui ont été qui est qui se sont exprimés
qui sont assez malmené en ce moment je
leur dis que je les comprends je les
encourage à essayer une transition
agricole d'aller vers le bio ça se fait
déjà beaucoup d'un circonscription il ya
beaucoup d'agriculteurs bio qui s'en
sortent justement veut pas trop mal je
le redis que le productivisme à tout
prix ne fonctionne plus aujourd'hui
quant à marie coll on peut plus produire
des tonnes et des tonnes et des tonnes
de produits et les écouler à un prix
raisonnable
je les encourage
comment dire avery a changé de modèle
agricole bnda blement vous pouvez être
certains pouvaient intervenir si vous le
souhaitez vous en prie à l'idée non
parce que moi en fait c'est toujours
pareil on fait des agriculteurs une
catégorie mais en fait ils ont la même
prime que toutes les boîtes c'est quoi
leur prime de foncer les charges baisser
les charges voudrais revenir sur moi ou
vous adresser au nom mais 2e
circonscription après l'accession
section pareil c'est qu'en fait
l'agriculteur et puis c'est pareil c'est
mon métier donc je suis tranquille le
problème de fond c'est le même c'est
toujours le même c'est vous produisez
quelque chose et ce produit doit vous
faire vivre donc ses prix de vente
alors on va pas revenir sur les 32
heures puisque un agriculteur je crois
que tant d'horreurs et comprendraient
pas puis la vache et sous la selle passe
pas entre est tellement mais au-delà de
ça je pense que si vous réduisez les
charges des agriculteurs et la
réglementation derrière et pourront
vivre de leurs produits et après on
pourra ré orienter les femmes et les
charges pardon si on veut que les
charges exigeant rien sur le sur la
consommation si vous produisez nommé
vous certaines villes mais si ils le
vendent faut-il encore que les ventes si
les prix ne baissent pas si les frais
sont pas accessibles si les produits ne
sont pas intéressants mais quand nathan
ne modifieront pas leur mode de
consommation ce qu'il faut c'est aider
les gens aussi à consommer différemment
sinon on a beau mais si leur charge ça
changera rien pour combler falla au
quotidien là ce que demande des
agriculteurs c'est ce que nous ont tous
les patrons condé boîte c'est moi on
veut vivre de notre travail est
aujourd'hui pour israël il faut produire
le prix de vente doit être supérieure à
nos charges lui c'est pas possible vous
interromps parole sur le plan de
l'agriculture en france il y a deux
modèles je veux simplement très
rapidement revenir sur le temps de
travail en disant que vous s'orienter
vers les 32 heures je suis opposée à ce
dispositif que 32 heures on va réussir
sans peut-être le seul à proposer de
solutions créatives à 32 heures on va
embaucher un million de personnes
passons à 16 heures avant d'embaucher 4
millions parti dans ce principe
normalement on devrait arriver à
compenser les gains de productivité qui
sont à l'origine du chômage ont toujours
été accompagnés de baisse du temps de
travail et c'est ce qui a permis de
maintenir l'emploi
c'est vrai mais pendant tous les deux
vers paris tarbes histoire vous pourrez
le constater pas dans tous les domaines
simplement dans l'agriculture en france
entre deux modèles en france on a la
chance d'avoir des produits d'exception
nous sommes les champions du monde de la
cuisine les champions du monde de la
production de produits de qualité que ce
soit dans les 20 dans les volailles dans
le la viande bovine dans la charcuterie
dans les matériaux transformés
nous sommes les champions du monde sur
plein de plans ça c'est un modèle que
l'on doit continuer à travailler faire
perdurer et encourager le monde agricole
dans cette voie le deuxième modèle qui
existe c'est la production de masse et
la production de masse on se moque du
monde agricole depuis trente ans tous
les tours et tous les politiques sont
passés par là se sont moqués d'eux on
leur a jamais dit la vérité c'est-à-dire
que si on veut faire la production de
masse est compétitif il faut avoir des
fermes de millevaches et pas de 150
vaches pour être compétitif produire du
lait au prix attendu et sans avoir
réellement besoin de compensation
financière de l'état ou de l'europe ce
que refuse le monde agricole puisque ils
veulent comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure ils veulent gagner leur vie de
leur travail
donc aujourd'hui il faut qu'ils revoient
ou leur dit la vérité aux lors des
usines ferment trop petit ça ne marche
pas il faut changer où on leur dit vous
associer pour rentrer dans le modèle qui
existe en land qui existe en allemagne
et vous serez compétitif sur la
production de masse donc on a bien deux
modèles est deux modèles ne peuvent
vivre pour nouvelle donne vous êtes à
peu près tout ça
minutes entre 3 minutes 30 et 4 minutes
de temps de parole moins de trois
minutes alors vous avez le temps draper
ce retard allez je peux donc m'exprimer
même si les autres peuvent intervenir et
chose intéressante ont été dites mais
elles sont toutes restées à l'intérieur
du cadre
l'honnêteté intellectuelle commandes de
déborder le cadre que se passe-t-il
aujourd'hui si on voulait aider les
agriculteurs effectivement dans
l'agriculture il existe deux modèles et
on tend de plus en plus vers le modèle
unique qui est le modèle de la grande
concentration industrielle et une
production industrielle
si on veut sortir de ce cadre pour aider
les petits agriculteurs à survivre
peut-être faudrait-il fixer des prix
plancher pour un certain nombre de
produits hélas aujourd'hui on ne le peut
pas et pour quelle raison est ce qu'on
ne le peut pas on ne le peut pas parce
que les règlements communautaires
l'empêchent donc une des premières
priorités pour ne pas rester focalisés
sur notre nombril c'est d'élargir le
débat et de voir de quelle manière nous
pourrions renégocier les traités
la seconde chose c'est par rapport aux
camarades de gauche là qui vient de
s'exprimer
nous sommes tout à fait d'accord il faut
produire local et il faut absolument
essayer de s'orienter vers le bio le bio
c'est bon pour tout le monde ça produit
des choses saines qui sont bonnes pour
les gens ça crée de l'emploi et ça crée
de l'emploi
et ça crée des de l'emploi et des
produits qui sont vendus à des prix qui
sont tout à fait compétitif et nous
sommes très bon là dedans et c'est pour
cette raison que je pense que le
problème de l'agriculture doit être pris
dans sa globalité que les traités
doivent être renégociés avec nos
partenaires et pas simplement sur
l'agriculture mais sur un grand nombre
de points et qu'il faut absolument que
nous revenions à une agriculture de
proximité
le local et le bio jérémy visait s'avoue
satisfait je serai un peu contradictoire
il ya un truc qui est en train de se
développer qui est assez innovant et qui
rejoint ce que vous dites
en fait je pas si vous avez regardé la
charte paris culteurs c'est en fait
maintenant avoir des productions
verticale de production agricole dans
les villes alors il y en a deux trois
qui vont sortir en fait ici une 5 6 ans
et en fait quelque chose qui est
totalement nouveau c'est qu'en fait on
va produire dans nos villes et plus de
façon horizontale parce qu'ils aient
plus de foncier mais de façon verticale
donc ça c'est des choses qu'on développe
aussi la mairie de paris
c'est assez innovant et je pense que ça
peut être une réponse
à ces pratiques de fruits ou légumes qui
arrive de très très loin si demain on
arrive à poser de façon verticale une
production de légumes ou de fruits
voilà ça peut être une encore une
innovation intéressante
heureusement que tout le monde soit
d'accord avec les positions nouvelle
donne c'est une position s'il est
accepté par tous est reconnu de tous
puisque le circuit court fait partie
d'eux des modes de production et de
consommation et quand on parle
d'écologie
je pense qu'un des premiers pas à faire
par tous les citoyens c'est de respecter
les circuits courts et de faire
travailler les producteurs locaux pour
vous dire que dans les yvelines on est
quand même aussi champion dans le
domaine de l'agriculture puisque au
dernier salon de salon avicole les les
yvelinois ce revenu avec trois médailles
une pour la charcuterie une deuxième je
connais cibrian hier et une troisième
pour pour je ne m'en souviens plus
exactement on va bientôt passer quatre
avions de combat vos conclusions
respectives sur sur ce débat puisque
nous sommes à bientôt bientôt une demi
heure de discussion sur cette seconde
partie de débat mais gm et visez vous
avaient le plus de retard et j'ai quand
même envie de vous poser la question et
les autres n'auront pas l'occasion de
réagir
voilà pour le temps de parole mais c'est
juste que le mandat sera très très court
si vous êtes élu quelle sera votre
priorité
et comment vous allez vous faire
entendre à soutenir le commerce local
mais soutenir l'agriculture locale alors
comment me faire entendre c'est mon
indépendance des partis traditionnels
fait que je pourrais avoir tous mes
collègues députés et essayer de faire
avancer un certain nombre de sujets pour
le commerce mais c'est les charges mais
c'est la tva avoir des mots des mots des
leviers pour modifier la donne pour les
autres points ce sera aussi plus tôt sur
le pnr de la vallée de chevreuse essayé
de protéger le pnr qu'aujourd'hui un peu
menacée par de grandes infrastructures
immobilières pour la bonne et simple
raison que la loi à lui récemment mis en
place
d'ailleurs par cécile duflot impose un
certain nombre de logements sociaux
nantes pour certaines même toutes
petites communes et qui devront donc
grignoter sur les terres agricoles
grignoter sur les espaces naturels ce
qui n'est pas acceptable pour un pnr qui
fera que les communes concernées qui
sont la ville bonnet et bullion l'onel
qui n'est pas ma circonscription
nous pourrons plus dans le bénin on va
passer aux différentes conclusions
pendant que les temps de parole sa fiche
on va faire un dernier tour de table
vous aurez tous à peu près une vingtaine
ou trentaine de secondes quelques
secondes de plus pour vous puisque vous
avez un truc le plus de retard on
commence avec vous pour nous citoyens
didier blanchard alors si je suis élue
la première chose que je ferai c'est un
laboratoire citoyens dans les
circonscriptions pour mettre en oeuvre
une plateforme citoyenne où tout le
monde puisse s'exprimer en sortir des
idées qu'ils soient apportées au niveau
national puisque quand je disais tout à
l'heure nous citoyens c'est vraiment la
troisième voie puisque on va voir une
bagarre meurtrière à gauche comme à
droite dans les partis traditionnels où
on va avoir une extermination quasi
certaine lors des prochaines élections
et je crois que la position de nous
citoyens de position centrale qui
permettra de rassembler un maximum
d'électeurs de jeunes et de gens qui ont
eu jusqu'à maintenant désertées lisions
être s'arrête là et c'est très bien
max al ahmadiah pour nouvelle est bien
un nouvelle donne nous voulons redéfinir
un nouveau contrat social qui soit basée
sur la protection le partage et
l'innovation
je reprendrai une phrase d'einstein qui
disait il ne faut pas compter sur ceux
qui ont créé des problèmes pour les
résoudre
eh bien c'est exactement ça qui se passe
aujourd'hui nous ne comptons pas sur les
partis en place qui ont fait faillite
depuis bien longtemps pour résoudre des
problèmes qu'ils ont eux mêmes créés
c'est pour ça que nous porterons tous
nos efforts pour que le maximum de voix
viennent se portaient sur nouvelle donne
et que nous puissions construire un
avenir viable et plus optimistes pour
tous nos concitoyens
kevin cantos votre conclusion parlons
oui elle a au moins écoutés non ma
l'idée c'était juste de dire en fait la
racine de nos mouvements c'est
l'écologie intégral et lequel mot
écologie parce que à la fois c'est mon
métier vous l'avez compris est à la fois
parce que c'est on fait partie de la
nature et on est dans la nature
mais quand je mets intégral y aussi le
respect de la vie et moi je pense que
les gens qui sont avec moi aujourd'hui
s'ils veulent un député qui se battent
c'est pour que cette ce respect de la
vie de la conception à la mort soit
vraiment défendu mais en tous les cas
moi c'est mon engagement et c'est ce qui
me motive aujourd'hui voilà pas trop
conclusion pour france écologie
ben moi ce que j'ai envie de dire aux
électeurs de la seconde circonscription
c'est de voter pour un candidat
indépendant de terrain j'ai toujours
vécu en vallée de chevreuse d'essayer le
changement mais changement pour
l'indépendance merci à tous les cadres
d'être venus débattre c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale du 7-8 politique
est retrouvé en replay sur notre site
internet et puis bien sûr le point
complet sur les résultats dans le
journal de lundi dès 18h en est direct
et 19h pour la première rediffusion
réalisation du débat signé et xavier
jaglin merci de nous avoir suivis les
programmes se poursuivre sur tv fils